joe biden has made it 50 years in
politics
without having to take a stand on
anything joe biden has been an empty
suit
blowing in the wind and it's actually
worked out pretty well for him because
he keeps getting elected to the senate
then he was vice president
and now he's gotten this nomination to
be the democratic nominee
for president during the last debate
president trump
forced joe into taking a stand he's
probably going to reverse that stand any
second now
but he forced him into taking a stand
and it was very unfortunate for joe
biden because
that particular stance on the issue
could cost joe just enough votes in just
enough important states
to cost him the election the stance was
on
energy
why would you do that so hold on a
second right there you hear the
moderator who
who is a democrat she was better than
chris wallace better than the other
moderators but she was still obviously
pulling for joe running interference for
him
and as joe says yes i would transition
away from
oil i would transition away from fossil
fuels she just goes why would you do
that joe
what the question was supposed to be
probing to get more answers but you
could hear the exasperation in your
voice why
why would you say that pennsylvania's
gonna decide the election
he gives his reasoning because the oil
industry
pollutes significantly i said here's the
deal but that's a big statement
well if you let me finish the statement
because it has to be replaced by
renewable energy
over time over time and i'd stop giving
to the oil industry i'd stop giving them
federal subsidies
he won't give federal subsidies to the
to the gas she should be to the
uh to uh solar and wind yeah why are we
giving it to oil industry
we actually do contribute to solar and
wind that's maybe the biggest statement
in terms of business that's the biggest
thing okay because basically what he's
saying
is he is going to destroy the oil
industry
will you remember that texas would you
remember that pennsylvania oklahoma vice
president biden let me give you 10
seconds to respond and then i have to
get to the final question
uh mr president we have to cut you off
before you point out to people how
significant this is
it's very significant it was a big
misstep for joe biden but it was a night
of missteps for joe biden
we will discuss low energy no
energy joe i'm michael knowles this the
michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment from thursday from
the tech's animal how is it possible for
obama to go from a net worth of around
300 000 when he took office
to a net worth of around 33 million when
he left office
there is a legitimate explanation for
this
which is barack obama wrote these two
books the first book is dreams from my
father which actually wasn't that bad he
might not have written it himself who
knows he might have had a ghostwriter as
a lot of politicians do but maybe he did
the book was readable and didn't sell a
ton of copies when it came out but then
when you're running for president people
buy your book then he wrote a political
book called the audacity of hope
that was certainly ghost written and it
was absolute trash
but that sold a lot of copies too so you
can make money basically hawking books
when you become a prominent politician
make a little money after you leave
office making speeches
then you make a little bit of money with
a netflix deal all legitimate all
you know especially the netflix deal a
little bit a little bit of corruption
there
because it's just so part of the
establishment
but okay it's all totally legal
then there are other questions like we
have right now for joe biden joe biden
were you getting
some money off the top were you skimming
off the top with some of these corrupt
deals your son had
i don't know there aren't really
allegations about that with barack obama
none in particular
but but there are questions that float
around with all of these politicians
how did maxine waters get such a nice
house she's been in government her whole
life how did joe biden get such a nice
house he's been in government his whole
life how did
nancy pelosi how did this one headed
that one
they all seem to be living pretty large
and maybe they can point to individual
legal means of getting that money but
when you look at the whole you say
it's a little unseemly for people to be
enriching themselves
off of the public service which joe
biden has certainly
done now he just wants to make everybody
else poor by banning the energy industry
even the media have had to call joe
biden
on this issue particularly local media
which tend to be more honest than the
national media
so right now a cbs affiliate out of
philly
after that poor debate performance for
biden
come out and ask him about fracking
industry leaders are concerned that if
you win demand for pennsylvania coal
will decline significantly as we move
toward
green energy you also talked about
transitioning
away from oil what would you tell these
families here in pennsylvania who are
concerned about this
what's happening with coal is that
people aren't building coal-fired
facilities anymore
because it's more expensive now and so
the transition has to
take place that we have to make sure we
take care of those folks that in fact
are unrelated to anything we propose
that's what's happening
secondly you know they talk about
fracking i'm not talking about
eliminating fracking
i just said no more fracking on federal
lands number one
number two you know we should be and
with regard to
gas oil coal all of it the transition is
taking place having nothing to do with
anything i'm proposing
the fact is that the fastest growing
industries in the country
are solar and wind joe biden
can't answer the question he can't
answer the question on fracking so he
fills in with all of these little
caveats well i'm talking about subsidies
well
i'm talking about this well i'm talking
about that he was asked by
an affiliate in wilkes-barre nbc
affiliate out there
what about the energy what do you want
americans especially those who are
connected to the natural gas industry
and fossil fuel industry
what they can expect under a biden
administration should you be elected
i would do not i will not ban fracking i
said no fracking on federal land i will
not
ban fracking number one number two
the coal and assuming the natural gas
industry
and oil is not going to be fundamentally
changed
they're already in transition what i'm
saying is that we will not
continue to subsidize give tax breaks to
the oil companies which
amount to 40 billion dollars they will
not get that
and that money will be put into research
and development to figure out how to
carbon capture what's coming off of gas
and oil
so first of all whenever i hear about
the oil subsidies
it it drives me crazy because the the
people pushing for oil subsidies
very often are democrats
some republicans too because you know
what oil subsidies are
it's giving money to poor people to heat
their homes in the winter
that is very often what an oil subsidy
is
how is that an oil subsidy well because
people need to heat their homes in the
winter
and the government has various programs
to come in and help people who can't
afford to do that
heat their homes in the winter and that
money is passed along to
who you guessed it oil and gas companies
because they're the ones who provide the
fuel to heat your home
you're going to get rid of that joe
you're going to say yeah we're going to
get all those poor families to freeze
during the winter
i don't think so and you would i don't
think you're going to do that and you
wouldn't want to do that even if you
could that's the big subsidy but then
listen to what he says
he says listen we're not going gonna
ban energy we're not gonna change energy
at all we're just it's gonna go away
but naturally it's gonna go away and and
not through me well i'll help it along a
little bit okay well if you're gonna
help it along
using the government writing new laws
then obviously
it's not happening naturally you can't
have it both ways but that's what joe's
always wanted to do he wants to have
every position of every single issue
scranton abc affiliate
same question mr vice president in the
debate we talked about phasing out
oil what does that mean for the natural
gas industry here in pennsylvania that
employee
i didn't say thank you for asking the
question what i said was we're going to
re
stop the subsidies for oil which is
about 40 billion dollars we're going to
take that money invested in new
technologies for what they call
carbon capture we're going to still need
oil we're going to still we're going to
still have
combustion engines we're still going to
need oil for many things
but what's happening is you have to do
it and we can work toward getting it
done so you can capture the carbon
that comes from that gas and that oil
that's what has to be done
we're we're going to invest money into
carbon capture technology that's that's
how you're explaining away your position
at the debate that you're going to get
rid of oil
those are completely separate things you
can't i don't remember hearing
a lot about carbon capture during the
debate
i wish i could see what's going on in
joe's mind i wish
i could see exactly where he thinks
this issue is going to lead him like if
i had a fight a camera in joe's mind
fortunately i have a camera outside of
my home
and that is thanks to ring you know
there's a thousand reasons why
protecting your home matters to you ring
has security products
for every corner of your home inside and
out best of all you can see it all in
one
simple app with ring you can keep an eye
on your home no matter where you are
right from your phone
if someone stops by or something's going
on ring will let you know it gives you
peace of mind
anytime whether you're in your house
whether you're at the office
whether you are on a beach somewhere as
you know i've been giving out rain to my
friends for years as housewarming gifts
but now i'm going to have a nice big
beautiful home in tennessee
we're in l.a we all live in little
hovels in tennessee we're gonna have
like nice big places
and sweet little lisa's a good shot but
i'm very excited that i'm gonna have
ring
to give me a little bit more of peace of
mind when i get out there
get a special offer on the ring welcome
kit at ring.com
knowles comes with a ring video doorbell
3 and chime pro
the perfect way to start your ring
experience plus free
two-day shipping go to ring dot com
slash knowles canada
that is ring dot com slash knowles can
it w-l-e-s
so you've heard joe dancing around all
of this no i didn't mean
we're gonna get rid of oil no i didn't
mean we're gonna get rid of fracking no
i meant we're gonna have new technology
no i mean we're gonna phase it out no i
mean it's facing out naturally no
okay what's your actual stance well here
is joe biden from just a few months ago
would there be any place for fossil
fuels including coal and fracking in the
biden administration
no it would be we would we would work it
out we would make sure it's eliminated
and no more subsidies
for either one of those i guarantee
we're gonna end
fossil fuel no more no new fracking and
i'd gradually move away from fracking
and i think it's critically important on
day one that we end
any fossil fuel leases on public lands
what about say
stopping fracking and stopping pipeline
infrastructure
they want to do the same thing i want to
do they want to phase out fossil fuels
and we're going to phase out fossil
fuels
there's no question i'm in favor of
banning fracking
now you heard him mention subsidies in
there but he didn't say what i'm talking
about is getting rid of subsidies he
said
yeah we're going to get rid of oil we're
going to get rid of fracking we're going
to get rid of energy and we're going to
get rid of subsidies
okay and so that's additional but the
rest it's pretty clear no new fracking
we're going to get rid of fossil fuel
how does joe biden do this because he's
a typical politician and he talks out of
both sides of his mouth this was
actually one of the best moments in the
debate for
president trump he called joe biden out
for this joe biden gave a very
smarmy unctuous sort of politician line
and and trump sort of broke the fourth
wall
broke the framework of the debate and
said oh my gosh did you hear this
what a politician this isn't about
there's a reason why he's
bringing up all this malarkey there's a
reason for it
he doesn't want to talk about the these
the substantive issues
it's not about his family and my family
it's about your family
and your family's hurting badly if
you're making less than
if you're a middle-class family you're
getting hurt
badly right now you're sitting at the
kitchen table this morning deciding
but we can't get new tires they're bald
because we have to wait another month or
so
or are we going to be able to pay the
mortgage or who's going to tell her she
can't go back to
to community college they're the
decisions you're making
in the middle class families like i grew
up in scranton and claim on
they're in trouble we should be talking
about your families but that's the last
thing he wants to talk about
i want to say i want to talk about north
korea
10 seconds mr president ten seconds
political statement
let's get off this china thing and then
he looks the family around the table
everything
just a typical politician when i see
that let's talk about that
politician okay that's why i got elected
let's get off the subject of china let's
talk around
sitting around the table come on joe you
can do better we're going to talk about
north korea now
oh no if you look at joe's
face during that clip you can see he's
really good at the performative the big
grin
and the kind of forced fake laughter and
he's really good at all of that
when trump calls him out for just
sounding like a typical politician
because he doesn't want to talk about
china
his f he looks he looks like you
you killed his puppy i mean he looks so
shocked that someone could do that
that it it he it's never happened to him
before
nothing like that has happened to him
before it reminds me back in 2016
when marco rubio gave some kind of
stupid political statement
and and chris christie walks up there
and again another kind of new york new
jersey guy and he goes
yeah you hear that there it is there's
the 15 second cant speech listen to
rubio he just it's like you turn him on
like a robot and
then rubio just repeated it verbatim
which is did not make the situation
any better so i thought that was a great
moment for trump the other great moment
for trump where he kind of broke out of
the framework of the debate which was
all working against him right you had a
moderate
moderator quote unquote who was much
fairer than the other ones but
still left wing she just happened to be
much
better than chris wallace or these other
people that we've seen
at other debates they were all working
against trump and he broke out
actually at one point by complimenting
the moderator he he said
thank you very much for being respectful
i appreciate it schools they need a lot
of money to open they need to
deal with ventilation systems they need
to deal with smaller classes
more teachers more pods and he's refused
to support that money or at least up to
now
let's talk about schools president trump
i think we have to respond if i might
please and then i have a phone thank you
and i appreciate that look all he does
is talk about shutdowns
so the thank you the i appreciate that
at one point in the debate he says
thanks for how you're handling this
you're doing well handling this what was
that about
is it because he's a really nice guy
maybe it is i don't know i don't know
the man personally
what i think this was about is that he
realized that the audience for these
debates
tends to skew older more senior citizens
people are going to decide this election
skew older they're senior citizens
and they don't want the cacophony and
the constant interruptions
and the zings and the zhang's and the
things that you know younger voters
might get a kick out of
i think older voters find that to be a
little disrespectful so he was much more
respectful and then when they got on the
topic of coronavirus i felt that the
distinction here
in tactic was really clear joe biden was
all doom and gloom president trump sunny
and hopeful
he's this is the same fellow told you
this is going to end by easter last time
this is the same fellow who told you
that
don't worry we're going to end this by
the summer we're about to go into a dark
winter
a dark winter and he has no clear plan
and there's no prospect
that there's going to be a vaccine
available for the majority of the
american people before the middle of
next year
president trump your reaction he says
you have no plan to have a dark winter
and at all we're opening up our country
we've
learned and studied and understand the
disease which we didn't at the beginning
when i closed and banned china from
coming in heavily infected and then
ultimately europe
but china was in january months later he
was saying i was xenophobic i did it too
soon now he's saying oh
i should have i should have you know
moved quicker
all you heard from biden was this
disease is going to kill you
be afraid be very afraid you're all
going to die and trump said don't worry
about it
look i had i had the thing i had three
days later i was fine
don't be afraid whenever you're a
challenger candidate and you're running
against an incumbent
you you have to portray the current
situation
as unpleasant so that you have a reason
for people to to vote for you
however there's a big difference between
my opponent passed a law that's really
bad and i'm going to repeal it
and there's a a virus that came in from
china and it's it's an
external threat and it's harming all of
us and
therefore you're all going to die and
it's all really terrible one
is is politics and you can play in
politics but the other one
is from abroad the other one is supposed
to unite us all as americans and we're
supposed to grit our teeth and get
through it together
and joe biden couldn't do that it was so
dark it was such a
such a horrible thing to tell people and
i i strongly suspect the people watching
this debate
would have preferred the more hopeful
sunnier
confident it's all going to be okay
joe attempted some of this hopeful
rhetoric
actually just by stealing a line from
obama's speech joe biden is
famous infamous for stealing lines from
people's speeches he had to drop out of
the 1988 presidential race because he
was stealing lines
from people's speeches over in ireland
and
so he did this with obama he stole
specifically obama's most famous line
they're not a red america they're not a
blue america they're the united states
of america it's completely meaningless
stupid line
but he took it to try to seem optimistic
problem was because joe biden
does not have quite as many brain cells
as barack obama to rub together
joe biden immediately undercut the
statement that he stole
i don't look at this in terms of the way
he does blue states and red states
they're all the united states
and look at the states that are having
such a spike in
the coronavirus they're the red states
they're the states in the midwest
of the states in the upper midwest
that's where the spike is occurring
significantly
but they're all americans they're all
americans
i don't see the difference between the
red states and the blue states but what
i see is that the red states are the
problem and the blue states are good
joe did you listen to he probably didn't
even read the line he stole
he just you know he's just it's so easy
just comes he goes yeah that sounded
pretty good when obama said that thing
okay i'm gonna say it
but he doesn't understand what it means
and so again both sides
of his mouth speaking of division by the
way
joe biden and the democratic moderator
because they were losing the debate
went back to the only emotional attack
line that has consistently worked
throughout the trump administration it's
the only terrible awful thing they can
accuse trump of which is
he separated children from their parents
at the border right he put put kids in
cages
but you put kids in cages you monster i
would never do that
so they launched that line of attack but
trump was prepared for it
they got separated from their parents
and it makes us a laughing stock and
violates every notion of who we are as a
nation
let me ask you a friend they did it we
changed the policy your response
we did not they built the
let's talk about who built the cages
let's talk about what we're talking
about
well we're talking about the cages well
let's i want to talk about what we're
talking about i don't want to be talking
about the thing we're not talking about
who built the cages joe well i don't
want to talk about that
because the biden the biden the obama
biden administration built the cages
those photos that were going around
showing kids in cages and was so awful
and trump's the devil
turns out those photos were from 2014.
president trump doesn't get elected
until 2016. they were from the obama
administration so
he cuts him off right there and then he
makes a point about these kids separated
from their parents very often
they're not being brought over by their
parents
talk about immigration now gentlemen and
we're going to talk about families
within this context mr president your
administration
separated children from their parents at
the border at least 4 000
kids you've since reversed your zero
tolerance policy
but the united states can't locate the
parents of more than 500 children
so how will these families ever be
reunited
children are brought here by coyotes
and lots of bad people cartels
and they're brought here and they used
to use them to get into our country
we now have as strong a border as we've
ever had
we're over 400 miles of brand new wall
you see the numbers and we let people in
but they have to come in legally and
they come in through
but how are you reuniting with their
families
so it's it's not president trump's fault
necessarily that he didn't have the
answer on this
and none of us i think knew the answer
on this until the department of homeland
security came out with it
but the premise of that question is
complete bs
right now there are 485 cases
where kids have been separated from
their parents
and it's under litigation not in
one single case has the department of
homeland security
found the parents and the parents wanted
the kids back
in their country of origin not in one
case
485 cases have
the parents have been contacted by the
department of homeland security and said
we've got your kid here
we will reunite you with your kid in the
country of origin
not in one case have the parents wanted
the kids back
why because they're sending their kids
to america there could be a perfectly
sympathetic or you know understandable
explanation for this
but don't tell me that donald trump
won't unite the kids with their parents
they're doing their best dhs would like
nothing more
than to unite the kids with their
parents in their country of origin
but that doesn't mean that you get to
just blow out the open borders and
and abolish our immigration laws and let
anybody come in
we already let what two million people a
year in vast majority of americans want
that number to be
dramatically lower by 50 or more
according to some polls
can't do that can't do that and if the
parents don't want their kids back we
can't make them
take the kids back he used the phrase
coyotes some
people don't know what that word means i
think our our national iq
has dropped pretty significantly you
know people can't do very simple things
like me i can't go into an auto parts
store and know exactly what i'm getting
thankfully there's rockauto.com
rockauto.com is so much easier
than walking into a store and then
someone demanding a quick answer to
something like hey
do you have the 2017 doodad gizmo or do
you need the
2019 lxex and i don't know what that i
don't know what any of those
numbers or letters even mean and then by
the way when you say what part that you
need usually the people at the auto
parts store what do they do they go into
the back
then they go online they probably go to
rockauto.com they order the port and
they charge you twice as much don't
don't do that
go to rockauto.com you can go to it at
your desk
in your pocket rockauto.com is a family
business they've been serving auto parts
customers online for 20 years
the website is so simple to navigate
even i can do it
i don't know anything about cars even i
can navigate their website and they've
been serving autoport's customers
online for basically as long as the
internet has been around
these are these guys are totally
reliable
the prices are always reliably low you
don't need to wait for some gimmick or
anything like that
head on over to rockauto.com right now
see all the parts available
for your car or truck write knowles know
wlas
in there how did you hear about his box
and that way they will know
that we sent you trump mentions that
these coyotes these you know these
criminals are bringing
the kids over apparently some some
people on the left
don't know what coyotes are there was a
state representative
darshan kendrick darshan kendrick is a
state rep in georgia tweet that did
donald trump just say 545 kids can't
find their parents
for came over through cartels and
coyotes
how the heck does a coyote bring a whole
human across the border lord stop
talking final debate thank you when i
saw that i thought
it i guess she's kidding too i
i there's no way she really but i think
actually
she thought he was talking about the
animal coyotes
not the criminals who are animals
frankly if you ask me
uh bringing the human beings across i
just love that idea like good lord stop
talking are you that stupid trump
when people say that very often
they are the ones who are missing
something such as david hogg he was that
kid
who became a micro celebrity after
a school shooting and he he led the
fight to essentially abolish the second
amendment and then he
was admitted to harvard for doing that
david hogg
tweeted out imagine calling the
immigrant parents that bring their
children to the united states for a
better life
coyotes the level of xenophobia is
sickening
and again i wish i wish he i could say
he were kidding but i suspect
he is not he is not and we
need to raise the voting age in this
country how old is david hawk is like 19
years old or something like that
he should not be voting he should
whatever whatever age he
is we need to raise the voting age above
that number he's at harvard by the way
so he is at least according to the
liberal establishment he is
one of the truly elite intelligent
young young people in this country and
still
certainly should not be voting
especially probably should not be voting
california wants to lower the voting age
they want to allow some 17 year olds to
vote if the 17 year olds would be
old enough to vote in the general
election they want
to lower the voting age for them in the
primary elections
uh this is proposition 18 on the ballot
in just a couple weeks
obviously should be shot down
there's a push throughout the whole
country to lower the voting age
the one point i want to make here
is that we've now gotten it in our heads
that voting is the most wonderful thing
you can do and it's always a good thing
and there's no reason ever
not to vote and there's no reason ever
not to
abolish any any slight obstacle at all
to voting voting is a means
to an end voting is an instrument to get
good government if you don't know
anything
it is not helpful for you to vote it
does not help the country it does not
help you
you will not get magical superpowers if
you go out and vote
if you don't know anything about the
election or our politics or our
government
or our history it's not good
i would recommend in that case you not
vote
me if i didn't know anything about these
issues if i didn't know anything about
the candidates
i would excuse myself from the voting
process
because i would have nothing to offer
the voting process
we've now gotten it in our mind though
that voting is the most
perfect expression of our humanity which
is why you're seeing the left
just trying to erode all limitations on
voting felons should vote
a 17 year old 16 year olds should vote
peop by the way i'm not talking about
felons who have served their time and
they got out i'm saying even people in
prison right now the left wants them to
vote
all sorts of people should vote i think
we need to just reframe the issue a
little bit
what is the point of voting what is it
for we've lost the the idea
in in our society that things are
for something you see it in the sexual
revolution
most especially right because our sexual
nature is
for something it has a purpose but we've
lost sight of that
so people do all sorts of crazy things
but this cup
has a has a purpose has a tea loss as a
four
the cup is for getting coffee into
my mouth so that i can then have energy
and do my show
the the cup is not for
uh wearing as a hat the cup is not for
uh
playing the telephone game it's not for
those things
our government our constitution is for
something
we are for something we have a purpose
and for as long as we don't understand
what that purpose is
we are going to uh misunderstand things
are going to go haywire
politicians have a purpose they're
they're supposed to be for something
and this is actually the point with joe
biden joe biden doesn't stand
for anything joe biden is an empty suit
it's why he gets so
so stuck when he actually has to answer
a question it's why he offered one
concrete
policy during that debate the concrete
policy was
i'm going to destroy the energy industry
and it gets him into a lot of trouble
but any answer he would have given would
have gotten him into
trouble because no one knows what he's
for it's all just this kind of vague
sentimentality what are our politicians
for we have a politician in california
right now trying to cancel thanksgiving
you think that's what they're for i
don't think so it's one of the stupidest
i have heard in quite some time which we
will get to in a second but you know the
election is almost here we have an
amazing
day of programming for you on election
day our live stream starts
tuesday november 3rd at 3 p.m eastern 12
p.m pacific
this will feature special guests live
interviews
multiple all access live sessions and
this will lead up to a very special
episode of backstage
where we will be covering the results
with you in real time and even better
you can join daily wire now and get 25
off
with code election so you can watch all
of our election coverage
live on apple tv on roku members can get
our articles ad free
access to our all of our live broadcasts
and show library the full three hours of
the ben shapiro show readers pass
which is only available to daily wire
members
if you are considering an all-access
membership you get to join us on all
access live every night for online and
live stream discussions you also get not
one but two
leftist years tumblers and early and
sometimes exclusive access to new daily
wire products is that enough it should
be
go to dailywire.com 25 off using code
election we'll be right back with a lot
more
here are the guidelines if you're having
thanksgiving in california thankfully i
will be out of this state for
thanksgiving i would have ignored the
rules even if i were here
all gatherings must include no more than
three households
including hosts and guests so you know
you've got uh
three aunts and their families who could
come over now
i'm sorry you gotta pick two old aunt
beth
doesn't get to come to thanksgiving this
year she is the least favorite aunt you
can only pick two that they can come
over but
the other one no because if you invite
two people over
you won't get coronavirus but if you
invite a third person over you will get
coronavirus
i guess that's just science they
they cannot last for more than two hours
again if you have a two hour
thanksgiving dinner
you're okay but at two and a half hour
thanksgiving dinner you will get
coronavirus that is i guess
science gatherings that occur outdoors
are safer than indoor gatherings so all
gatherings must be outside i guess like
the first thanksgiving
that's really going back in history
you're not allowed to go indoors because
if you go indoors
you will get coronavirus by the way i i
have been ignoring all
all of these stupid rules from the very
beginning the masks and the social
distancing
and the indoors and the outdoors and
i've been ignoring all of it and guess
what
i'm having a great time my life is
totally fine
my friends lives are totally fine my
family's lives totally fine
you can do it you can do it it's okay
you don't need to listen
to these idiotic politicians those who
are at the thanksgiving gathering
quote may remove their face coverings
briefly to eat or drink as long as they
stay six feet away from everyone outside
their own household
and then they have to put the face
covering back on the minute they're done
with the activity
you get one little spoonful of cranberry
sauce in there but you better put that
mask on i don't care if it smears the
sauce
you got to do it otherwise otherwise you
will get coronavirus
face coverings can be removed to meet
urgent medical needs
such as taking an asthma inhaler if you
get an attack so you are allowed
you're allowed to take the mask off if
you are dying
you can take it off to get life-saving
medicine but otherwise you better put it
on
no singing no chanting no shouting no
physical exertion of any kind
is permitted if you do have to sing at
the table you've got to do it very
quietly in a speaking voice
behind a mask and
then you have to go home within two
hours
and obviously none of that is based on
science science itself has
very little to say about any of those
questions because those are ethical
and philosophical and political
questions and
all of them are not only medically
pointless
but but politically horrifically
perverse and corrosive
so you should ignore all of that i
intend on going to a thanksgiving dinner
and hugging and kissing everybody and
sharing plates and maybe even sharing
drinks with people
and singing very loudly and never ever
ever even considering wearing my mask
and i encourage all of you to do the
same because this is all very stupid
and these politicians are not going to
let off
even one little bit on this grip of
power that they've stolen from us
pointlessly uh unconstitutionally
unless we take it from them so just take
it just ignore them no reason to pay
any attention to them no reason to pay
any attention to dr fauci also
who should have been fired long ago and
i don't mean six months ago i mean like
35 years ago somehow this guy
has been in his job for 40 years more
than 40 years i think
not not great he said between 30 and 40
years i think
dr fauci says that the masks and the
measures are not going to go away
anytime soon
15 days to slow the spread forget about
that they're not going to go away
through 2022 even with a vaccine he says
it's not going to be the way it was with
polio and measles where you get a
vaccine case closed it's done
we're not going to have herd immunity
for a considerable period of time
into 2022 i feel strongly that we're
going to need to have some degree of
public health measures to continue
i don't i you know it's funny i feel
strongly that dr thatchy should get
fired
so you know you feel that way and i feel
this way and uh
and so let's go with my way fire fouchy
get rid of him there's just no reason to
have him on tv
if he goes on tv he should wear a mask
so that we can hear what what he has to
say
a lot of people believe that the
democrats are going to
give up this hysteria about covid after
the election
the the joke and i've said this too well
something tells me on november 4th all
this is going to calm down all the masks
are going to go away
i'm not so sure about that they've taken
a shocking amount of power and they have
fundamentally reordered
our public and social culture i don't
think they're going to give that up
that's a lot of power
so we need to take it we need to take it
back i'm i'm not going to wear the masks
unless i
have to in some immediate circumstance
to get on an airplane or
to go and pick up my sandwich or
whatever and i'll wear and then very
particular circumstance
and i will wear it below my nose just as
a very slight protest you can tell
people's political views
by exactly where on their nose and mouth
they wear their masks
but but regardless of that any other
time i'm going to ignore every single
one of these stupid measures
every single one and i encourage all of
you to as well the narrative is falling
apart
it's clear that that the left is is not
even
helping on the issue now the leftists
are not even helping the other leftists
jake tapper was just hammering nancy
pelosi on this issue because
they're obviously just manipulating it
for political purposes if
this were the greatest threat we've ever
faced then surely the democrats would
want to give out more covid relief money
right democrats love
giving out money to people that's what
they run on so trump says okay i'm
willing to sign a bill
give me the bill and pelosi says no jake
tapper says why not why won't you take
yes for an answer
let's just let's be hopeful we're nine
days before an election we're trying to
unify the country and one way to do it
is to come together to crush the virus
so we can open our economy
open our schools uh feed our people
17 million children who are insecure
in our country but again the answer is
crush
the virus so i i get that um but it just
seems like
they keep moving closer and closer i i
get that you're waiting for it on paper
but it just seems like you're winning i
mean that's what it seems like to me i'm
looking at all the things that the white
house is moving towards your position on
and it seems like you could take yes for
an answer
well as soon as they say this is it we
in
our negotiations yes that is the case
but then they
take it back and when they come back it
isn't always
it isn't what we anticipated huh
what what was that nancy huh she's just
sort of
babbling incoherently after tapper makes
this good point why won't you take yes
for an answer now you've got to remember
when the media push back on democrats
that is
a categorically different act than when
the media push back on republicans
it's the difference between fighting
with your enemy and fighting with your
lover
when when the media are hammering
republicans it is because they oppose
what the republicans are trying to do
when the media are hammering democrats
is because they're having a tactical
disagreement
they agree on where they want to go but
they're having a disagreement over which
tactics are going to work best and what
what tapper is saying here is
this doesn't look good nancy people are
waiting for you
to to give them the money for kovid if
you would just give them the damn money
that would help us all out
all of us liberals so just do it what's
wrong with you and what nancy pelosi is
saying is no we can't do it because
trump is going to get credit for it if
we do it
and it doesn't really matter we don't
care if people get the money and the
covet it's not even
as big a deal as we're all pretending
that it is so we're just holding it out
until the election
and then we'll change strategy and
they're just arguing back and forth
over what the tactic should be and
pelosi's answer is
you've just got to oppose trump all the
left has
is opposing trump the right faced this
problem a little bit under obama
especially with with regard to health
care health care is a very good issue
for democrats in this way
because they always have some big crazy
plan that's going to steal people's
choice and steal away their money
and destroy the health care system all
in the name of making it wonderful and
perfect and utopian
and the right never has an answer to it
because our answer on health care is
yeah we're going to make modest changes
here and there as they come we're not
going to overhaul the whole damn thing
we're not going to take away your doctor
we're not going to have some big
national program
because that's going to actually harm
the health care system which currently
currently is the best in the world but
that doesn't sound really good on
30-second tv ads you're not allowed to
say no we're not going to have a huge
fundamental change we're going to tinker
around here and there and make it better
and better as we've been doing for 100
years
so the democrats would say well you
republicans you don't have
a positive alternative you just oppose
obama and specifically obamacare and in
a way they were right
we we opposed much of their stupid plan
and
we the the positive ideas we had to
offer health savings accounts insurance
across state lines
those were relatively minor changes
compared to obamacare
now the situation has flipped after the
obama era all the left has his
opposition to trump saturday night live
was joking about this even saturday
night live
as left-wing as as television shows get
they they said that there's a big risk
here for democrats
because if they vote for biden then
trump might lose
and then they'll all have nothing to
talk about
everyone knows this could be the most
important election in our nation's
history
and the two choices couldn't be more
different do we want four more years of
donald trump
or a fresh start with joe biden can we
survive four more years of scandal
name-calling and racial division or do
we want a leader who unites the country
i want to vote for biden because he's
better smarter
better and better but i'm worried
i'm worried too because if donald trump
isn't president
then what are we gonna talk about like
where will our conversations even be
because the only thing i've talked about
for four years is donald trump
every single day i tell someone can you
believe what trump just said
my entire personality is hating donald
trump if he's gone
what am i supposed to do focus on my
kids again
no thanks i argue with my dad every day
about trump
before this we hadn't spoken in years
it goes on and on you can tell it's a
left-wing
sketch right they're saying biden's so
much better biden so much better
but they attack these leftists because
the leftists have nothing other than
hating trump
it's so bizarre to me because i get
these angry emails from friends and
relatives i get them
all the time people who have not thought
about politics very much
but they they think they're thinking
about it all the time all they're
thinking about is how much they hate
trump
and i get these emails it's terrible you
can't support trump you can't be a
republican you know
one gets them every single election
cycle it's not even
just exclusive to donald trump it's it's
exaggerated with donald trump but it's
not exclusive to him
and i always think
that you think it's immoral for me to
vote for trump okay i understand that
i think it's immoral for you to vote for
joe biden i think it's an
immoral thing to do i think you'll have
to answer for that at judgment day
for i'm i'm not joking this is not an
exaggeration i think you will actually
have to answer for voting for joe biden
at judgment day
because it is that immoral but i don't
harangue my democrat friends and
relatives all the time about it
because i understand that for most of
them i think it's an honest
misunderstanding they don't get it they
haven't thought about this too deeply
they haven't thought about the moral
issues underneath it too deeply
and the orange man's bad and they've
kind of been driven a little kooky by
that
and so they they're willing to do it
that's fine
what you have to answer for judgement
day is is your problem it's not
unfortunately i don't think i'm gonna
have to answer for you
the left can't understand that the other
way their entire personality has become
hating donald trump there are there are
whole twitter accounts
individuals who i've met in real life
whose whole twitter account is i hate
trump i'm i used to be a trump voter but
now i'm not a trump voter i hate
whatever hating donald trump is not a
personality
making your whole life about one
political candidate that's not
a personality life is much
much bigger than that you know i really
like trump i mean i'm a big supporter of
his
i like a lot of other republican
politicians and i've been
supporters of theirs friends of theirs
even in some cases
but that's not that's not my whole life
that's not my whole personality there
are other things in life
many other things called the forget the
political level at the cultural level
and ultimately of course
at the religious level the republicans
the conservatives the trump people
can explain right now what they're
voting for beyond just the man
we get a kick out of the man but we're
voting for some we're voting for
enforcement of our immigration laws
we're voting for protection
of our workers we're voting for
protection of our country our history
our culture our way of life in america
we're voting for all of those things
we're voting for the protection of our
churches we're voting for the protection
of law and order
what is the left voting for they can't
quite say it
that's why biden got tongue tied on the
energy question
on any single issue they're going to get
messed up on what they're voting for
that's why biden has to just be blowing
around in the wind
chelsea handler sum this up the chelsea
handler is that
i guess comedian is she a comedian she's
this white comedian
who said she got very angry at her
ex-boyfriend fiddy cent
because fiddy sense said he's going to
vote for trump
and and he explained why he's going to
vote for trump he said he's going to
vote for trump because trump is going to
keep his taxes relatively low and joe
biden is going to raise his taxes so
significantly that fitty cent would
become 20 cent
so he gave his reasoning chelsea handler
was so upset
that that she had to call and remind him
that he's black
that blacks aren't allowed to vote for
conservatives they have to vote for
democrats
you heard about my abs boyfriend right
50 cent and his support of
of uh donald trump yeah what's going on
between you i saw your tweets and i go
wait what's happening because
you said he was your favorite
ex-boyfriend and then he
what is he supporting trump he says he
doesn't want to pay 62 percent of taxes
which by the way is in a plan of
joe biden's that's that's that's a lie
so he doesn't want to pay 62
percent of taxes because he doesn't want
to go from being 50
to 20 and i and
i had to remind him that he was a black
person so
he can't vote for donald trump and that
he shouldn't be influencing
an entire swath of people who may listen
to him
because he's worried about his own
personal pocketbook so
i haven't heard back from him yet but i
am willing to
you know seal the deal in more ways than
one if he changes his mind and publicly
denounces donald trump i might be
willing to go for another spin if you
know what i'm talking about
everything about that is disgusting
everything first of all the idea that
chelsea handler
who you know how do i say this
respectfully
no spring chicken okay anymore is
going to prostitute herself so that this
guy
will vote for biden
is gross it's gross to think about it's
gross to do
the statement that this this white
liberal
is going to lecture a black man on how
because of his skin color he's not
allowed to vote
for republicans is gross
it's disgusting it's obviously untrue
the idea that joe biden won't raise some
people's taxes to 62 percent
she said that that's a lie that's not a
lie it's true it's true the reason she
doesn't understand this
is because she i guess she thinks
there's only such a thing as federal
taxes
but there are state and local taxes too
and when you add it up in places like
california the biden tax plan comes out
for many people including 50 cent
to 62 or maybe 63 actually
well the whole thing is gross but in
that in that whole
gross monologue to jimmy fallon who was
just as confused she goes
huh he's voting for trump huh what
that's so weird
in that whole monologue she never
explains
why fitty cent has to vote for biden
why all black people have to vote for
democrats why
she just makes a lot of insinuations
well
he's black i mean it's like i don't even
need to explain it
no you do explain it to me explain to me
why anybody should vote for biden well
trump's bad he o
right okay yeah i got it you think
trump's really bad
put that over here for a second why
should i vote for
joe biden instead of just voting against
donald trump i actually think it's
legitimate to vote against candidates
but just just as an intellectual
exercise
why do you why would you vote for this
guy
puts kids in cages no he didn't joe
biden actually started that but that's
fine neither here nor there
why would you vote for joe biden they
can't give you an answer because joe
biden himself is not for
anything joe biden licks that finger
puts it up in the wind and blows around
it's why he is a low energy candidate to
use the term that was applied to jeb
bush
in in 2016. jeb bush stood for a lot
more than joe biden ever has
but he's a low energy because he can't
take a position
the one time he gets backed into taking
a position it's on an issue that could
cost him the election
particularly in pennsylvania you see
the dilemma what is joe for or nothing
at all what are you for
what are you for less than two weeks
until the election
i'm michael knowles this is the michael
knowles show
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer
jeremy boring our technical director is
austin stevens
supervising producers mathis glover and
robert sterling
assistant director pavel wadowski editor
and associate producer
danny d'amico audio mixer robin
fenderson
hair and makeup nika geneva and
production assistant
ryan love the michael knowles show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire
20 20. if you prefer facts over feelings
aren't offended by the brutal truth and
you can still laugh at the insanity
filling our national news cycle
well tune in to the ben shapiro show
we'll get a whole lot of that and much
more
see you there